manager which is when will your project
be done how much is it going to get take
to to complete so those are really
really important questions that project
managers need to attend to yeah and as
you said the critical path method perk
charts and things like that where based
on the idea that projects were a a
set series of tasks that needed to be
done some in parallel some in series and
uh
critical path method especially says
identify the tasks that have to be done
one after the other in a particular
order so that the next task can't start
until the last task is complete when you
find when you find the series of those
that that defines how long your project
has to be then that's where you pay your
attention but that's not really
our project management works today is it
yeah well one of the interesting things
that we've uh witnessed more recently is
this shift to more of a digital uh way
in which companies provide services and
this is where you see some of the
techniques like the ones that we had
learned about and a lot of us are are
leveraging now like scrum which is part
of the agile family so just as you
pointed out uh in the past there was a
lot of you know upfront planning that
went into understanding how long
something was going to take to get done
and how much it would cost and those
techniques that we saw earlier still
very effective but increasingly what
we've discovered is in fact we can
deliver our projects Faster by really
finding ways in which we enable the
people doing the work so finding ways
that they can engage collaborate
interact
scrum and others in the agile family
really help us sort of break down those
silos of all the divided responsibility
that in the past we're a little more
effective for delivering projects but
now we work in sort of this digital
domain we've gone increasingly sort of
more Global uh perspectives on the
services and the products we offer so we
need to have something more responsive
more adaptive to change and scrum and
agile really helps us with that which is
why many organizations that are making
that pivot that shift to Agile delivery
because it allows them to respond more
quickly to change allows them to satisfy
their their markets more quickly and
helps them respond to big changes that
we often see like you know the pandemic
what do you do when those occur agile is
a pretty good answer to that
thank you so this is uh you know it's
still
in the in the scale of human of human
endeavor uh it's still fairly new right
it's a
it's a set of skills that
uh
you can apply universally
um
can you think of any part of uh the
Working World where project management
wouldn't be helpful you know it's so
interesting to ask that question because
really honestly there's no part of the
working world that project management
isn't going to be essential and in fact
it's like I said earlier not just every
industry every size of organization but
even us personally you know don't we all
at times have to apply project
management skills to how am I going to
organize the garage this weekend or you
know I've got all these tasks I need to
get done today which ones are the most
important
um what sequence do I need you've
highlighted dependencies you know we
need to think about that and we apply
those techniques and skills just in our
day-to-day activities so when we think
about how a large Enterprise needs to
think about delivering a large project
well project management is going to be a
critical skill that they need to really
apply and lean on yeah and if everything
was like uh ordering a piece of flat
pack Furniture
online and then having the instructions
to build it you would be able to follow
a series of tasks set order and get the
in know that you would reliably complete
the the project but the world around us
really isn't always like that so
um necessary to be able to understand
where the fixed tasks are and where the
processes are and how to interact
between those
yeah really good points think about the
process pieces you know we need to think
about what process we need to follow
um you know what are the things you know
as a project manager we're going to hear
more about but you're thinking not just
budget and schedule clearly those are
going to be important but risks
um people management how do we get
people engaged how do we uh sort of deal
with change management communication
those are all kind of Concepts that
become really important in the project
management domain yeah and uh at least
the other side of the equation you have
management always asking you you know
how how soon can we deliver this and how
much is this going to cost and how many
people are you going to need and all of
those types of
resource and uh
certainty questions yeah
you have to be able to answer to your
best of your ability but
certainty in an uncertain world is uh
nice thing to shoot for not always
achievable in the project managers
Challenge and responsibility is to try
to
deal with the uncertainties
bring things closer to the goals that
management have set
every industry every company every job
description really involves project
management skills as Brian said
the skills
spill over into your personal life
being able to figure out how to get
ready for a trip or to clean out the
garage or rebuild remodel your house or
plan for a
future promotion or new career all of
those things
are our personal aspects of project
management as well so
can you kind of take us through these
different aspects of
kind of
this is like looking at the
blind men looking at the elephant and
each touching a different part yes
but how can you take us through these
yeah absolutely so you know as you
pointed out these are Universal skill
sets every organization every Industries
could be interested in understanding
some of these uh Concepts particularly
when it comes to these important
initiatives and one thing to recognize
too is typically projects are vehicles
in which organizations are making
significant Investments and as a
consequence they're really interested in
all the way up to their senior executive
levels how well are those Investments
um progressing are they going to
generate the return that we anticipate
so often as a project manager you're
working closely with some of the most
senior members of an organization and
they need as we can see in this list
here some deliverables they're going to
help them better understand how you're
approaching this problem solving this
creating opportunities for the
organization so things like developing a
project plan let's think about all those
different activities as you kind of
pointed out some of them are on this
critical path let's understand where
that critical path is so we can protect
that and make sure it doesn't impact our
delivery dates
um also just understanding when do we
expect or need people to come in very
large projects or sometimes need to
bring on board 20 30 50 hundreds of
people so we have to get some thought to
where were they going to work and what
kind of tools and services they need so
the project plan becomes a really
important tool for a project manager to
kind of look at understand how work is
progressing are you on track how does it
affect your forecast and your budgets
and then of course you have deliverables
within that plan these are those
tangible uh assets that you're going to
create as part of delivering a project
sometimes they're documents sometimes
the reviews sometimes their
functionality uh any number of things
could be considered deliverables as a
project manager you want to have a clear
line of sight to what those are because
they're really instrumental in
determining how well you're progressing
you've got to bring project people on
you know the project itself is going to
be supported by people so as a project
manager you're often very involved in
identifying the right skill sets for the
different roles and deliverables that
you have in your plan and then of course
you're going to lead and manage these
teams so as a project manager you've got
to have good people and Leadership
skills a lot of times that involves
what's the intent what's the purpose
what what's the why behind the work that
we're doing and helping the team kind of
progress when we run into bottlenecks or
impediments you need to be there to help
remove those so they can continue to
deliver value and then methodologies and
that's just a way in which we describe
processes that you mentioned earlier
Stuart and you know there's different
types of processes some are more
conventional traditional often we call
those waterfall that kind of work in a
very linear fashion and then nowadays
we're using more agile practices which
are more focused on rapid delivery
getting feedback making adjustments all
that helps us determine a sketch
schedule that we can communicate both to
leadership and stakeholders but also the
people that are waiting for this new
functionality when they can expect to
get it and maybe even having phases that
we work through in our project and then
we get an opportunity to kind of assign
work to the people that we brought on
board and then message upwards to our
leadership our upper management
explaining how we're progressing and
where at times we might need help and
this is where leadership leans in and
you know supports the project yeah and
and
um that brings up the point of the
communication between the project
manager and the and the project team
members as well because you have to hold
not only assigned tasks to people but
you have to hold them accountable for
progress on those tasks
I remember
um
I remember at one point in my career
working with a manager who was
responsible for managing a team of
software developers but had no knowledge
of
the kind of skills and technology and
software development at the time and his
only ability in terms of
handling communication from his team
members was to say how much longer is
this going to take and when they would
answer you know
well it's going to take longer than I
thought
he wasn't able to interrogate them about
why is that what what
blockers or or
roadblocks are you running into how can
I help right
really an important skill to be able to
make that a two-way communication and
understand
um from the perspective of the project
manager well if it's going to take you
longer why is that where are the places
we can buy different resources and you
know understanding enough about the work
that's being done or what questions to
ask in order to be able to
manage that process intelligently so
there's a lot a lot of
different
aspects and communication skills
people management skills
technical skills of understanding
relationships between
tasks and being able to lay out a
schedule a budget all of those things
are make this kind of a kind of a
but you used to call a renaissance man
type of
right you have to be a you have to be
capable in a lot of different areas
exactly yeah so uh here are some
interesting quotes about project
management came across
um and the first one is from the project
management Institute with whom you work
um yeah
the
they are calling today's environment the
project economy and that comes from a
Harvard Business review article
from about a year ago so the project
economy is one in which people have the
skills and capability they need to turn
ideas into reality and that's really
what project is right
yeah essentially the end of the day
you've got these ideas you've got
opportunities you want to pursue maybe
challenges or problems you need to solve
and then how do you kind of manifest
those into something real and this is
what a project manager's role is really
about I often think of a project manager
a little bit like the conductor of an
orchestra you put all these different
instruments and performers they can be
highly skilled but it's up to that
conductor to kind of bring them all
together to create that powerful
Symphony that really kind of you know
affects and brings us to our feet so
that's really the role for project
management so taking those ideas making
them real yeah
um those who plan do better than those
who do not plan even though they really
stick to their plan is which Winston
Churchill
great leader of the 20th century Assad
and it relates to something that uh
Napoleon
uh no not Napoleon
the military strategist named Carl Von
klausswitz said which is uh your plan
will not survive first contact with the
Enemy right which is the idea that you
you make your plan and you
anticipate what you're going to do and
then you need to be aware that reality
will change
situation you're in dynamically and
you'd be able to adapt your plan
constantly
having the plan is very important
because otherwise you're just reacting
and not reacting
yeah structured way so important I like
to quote mine of the famous project
managers Mike Tyson who often says the
plan until they get punched in the face
that's the restatement of fine classical
exactly yeah
the next quote is really
um a important insight for project
managers and people who you know if you
go back to the first quote which is you
need to be able to turn ideas into
reality
um Henry Ford reminds us and Thomas
Edison used to say something similar
which is
when you fail that's not the end of the
of the road it's an opportunity to start
again
with more knowledge and more experience
than you had before so failure is simply
the opportunity to begin again this time
more intelligently that's a great thing
to remember and that's also an important
skill of project management yeah it
really is in fact these days in
particular project managers are being
looked to to kind of help organizations
understand is this a path we want to
continue to invest in and we need to get
results that tell us that in fact Yep
this is the right direction and if not
we need to Pivot or maybe even Park this
work and choose something else that we
want to pursue so um as a project
manager your organizational leadership
is going to be coming to you time and
time again and saying hey you know how's
this looking should we keep going down
this path so you really kind of are you
know you use the term entrepreneurial uh
when you're introducing me and I think
that's a really important element of
being a project manager you need to
assess is this the right investment for
your organization yeah
um and then of course Peter Drucker who
is one of the greatest management
experts and thinkers of the 20th century
also said
plans are only good intentions unless
they immediately degenerate into hard
work yeah
uh you you can have great plans and
great ideas but you have to to put in
the work to implement them and project
managers are the people who catalyze
that process who turn the idea into a
plan for the work and then Direct
the efforts around that work so it's
it's a really
Central set of skills is if you're a
formal project manager as your full-time
job
program manager
um that is an important role and if
you're in a more
other positions we've talked about
before
if you're in any other position
responsible within your organization
you have that same set of
responsibilities and skills that you
need to apply so
um good opportunity to remind everybody
you have questions for Brian please put
them into the Q a and we'll be getting
to those shortly yeah and um
tracking those there I'll try to look
through the chat as well
do put your questions in the Q a if you
can project management Institute
um
have done some recent studies
2.3 million people needed each year to
fill project management oriented
positions
by 2030 each year 2.3 million by 2027
employers will need a total of 88
million people worldwide employed in
project management oriented roles so
this is
a big part of the
working world in the world economy
a lot of opportunity
um
kind of a staggering number isn't it
yeah I mean but it really just tells you
to your earlier point this is so
instrumental to every organization every
industry you know project management
they leverage to grow and to expand and
to address challenges identify
opportunities so uh doesn't surprise me
we're seeing this and also you know
recognize you know we're in a very
exciting time in our our you know
societal civilizational development
we've got uh all these large initiatives
ranging from you know shifts to more
renewable energy uh of course everyone's
I'm sure heard about chat GPT artificial
intelligence so there's gonna be so many
projects emerging that organizations are
going to say yeah we want to leverage
those new ideas that are starting to
emerge we want to respond to some of
this market demand as we shift the
renewable energy usage and it's going to
be project managers driving all that
yeah if you think about uh what it took
to set up an online uh Enterprise
uh for example something like
uh sales force
back in the day that it was beginning
you had to obtain
uh server rooms and lots of Hardware to
create
large Computing resources for people to
tap into for their distributed software
as a service and you you had to uh
create all that infrastructure you had
to create all the software you had to
create all of the documentation you had
to create all of the user
interfaces
if you think about what it takes to get
started in a digital business today you
can turn to resources where you can get
computing power storage uh all that
available you can turn to resources that
will do
almost TurnKey uh
development of the user interfaces for
you you have chat GPT now as tools that
will help you generate documentation so
uh the real consistent challenge
between then and now is you need
somebody who understands all the parts
that have to be put in place how to
coordinate the work
so project management is one key skill
that still over oversees all of these
different tools
now that the tools are different in
resources are you know in a sense easier
to get you still have to have somebody
who understands how to deploy them
yeah definitely in fact one of the
things the project management Institute
has been tracking very closely is that
the need for these skills is so
pervasive in organizations that even
though you might not have a role of a
project manager these skills are still
going to be really really valuable in
any other role capacity in an
organization so you might be working in
HR Director of HR you're still going to
need project management skills you could
be working in the engineering domain
customer support so this is definitely
something that the PMI has witnessed and
they're really actually leveraging
pretty effectively kind of making these
ideas these Concepts these skills
available to a wider wider audience
because organizations are just needing
to pull on them so much yeah
so here's just a few of the the formal
job titles that are that fall under the
The Heading of project management but as
we just discussed
whatever title you're in you'll have uh
ability to leverage project management
skills but you talk about you know how
these different titles relate to each
other yeah absolutely so you know we've
got project managers of course that's
what we're spending a lot of time
discussing they're really the ones close
to the solution thinking about important
you know topics like budgets and
resourcing and schedules and risk
management we have program managers and
they often are pulling together several
related projects that together need to
execute to deliver some kind of outcome
so program managers kind of operating at
a little higher level and as a result
often have a bit more of a you know a
span of responsibility and Authority
within an organization and then you've
got agile scrum Masters and these are I
think a very exciting new role that has
emerged in a sort of a shift to a more
digital economy and uh address Chrome
Masters are really embedded with the
teams they're kind of where the the
action is and their boots on the ground
getting very close to the solution
working with teams identifying where
there's impediments or getting them out
out of the way for the team and what's
really powerful about this I think
Stuart is one is you've got very clear
sort of career paths that you can choose
to follow and you've got these branches
you can explore and you know for some of
us you know we're going to be a little
bit more interested in maybe working at
you know more the senior levels and
building out you know complex plans
thinking hard about uh you know those
bigger budgets portfolios but in some
cases too we might just want to be
closer to the work being done and we get
more satisfaction than that so what's
powerful about this career space is
you've got these paths open to you that
I don't think many other career areas
have the same degree of so this is part
of what gets me inside of a project
management you just have so many options
available to you yeah and then you think
about if you're an individual
contributor and you're being asked at
some point to lead a team of your fellow
contributors you know then you start
looking at well how do I do that and
what are the project management skills
I'll need to be able to coordinate the
work of the people around me so that's a
a perfect example of how somebody who
might not be in a quote-unquote project
management job uh needs to be able to to
draw on that same set of skills and then
these are just some random names I
pulled off of glass door from people who
are currently hiring in the field and
offering good jobs at good salaries
um
there are many other
things I could have listed Lockheed
Martin I could have listed sure
the government agencies of various types
uh all of whom are constantly looking
for people in these areas but these are
job listings
companies that have job listings up on
glassdoor.com right now all over the
world large National corporations not
always in the digital space
Amazon of course is digital uh
e-commerce Microsoft Google IBM Cisco
Cisco infrastructure Microsoft Google
IBM more in the digital space meta
social media topic consultancy emphasis
consultancy so here's
these this is one narrow slice of of the
world but any almost any uh company in
any industry is going to be out there
looking for project managers way shape
or form so
right right yeah other classic examples
you know think Tesla Tesla and Elon Musk
and SpaceX definitely leveraging a lot
of uh some of the best project managers
uh available because they know how
important it is and just again look at
these Marquee names any one of these
would be fantastic organizations to be
part of uh to to work within to learn
from so again this makes this a you know
very exciting area
um it's not just in this one space it's
it's you know Healthcare uh is drawing a
lot on project management uh
telecommunications uh all these areas
always need project management yeah I
was going to mention Elon Musk because
you we talked earlier about turning
ideas into reality and Elon Musk was
really great with big big ideas and
you might some people scoffed at him
when he said things like we're going to
send people to Mars right um but he
understood that there's a series of
projects you have to fulfill in order to
be able to get there and he built up a
business you know that
funds Itself by launching satellites for
other agencies and and uh gives ability
to develop the technology that will
ultimately deliver human beings to Mars
so it's it's kind of an interesting
example of using
you know
project management in an intelligent way
to build up a series of projects towards
an ultimate very large goal you get paid
well for this right oh yeah I mean these
are project project manager is kind of
the actual entry level title
program manager
a little bit step up in the career chain
agile scrum Master because it has
specific skills that are more
specialized coming out to higher salary
but you know how do people move you know
from the upper left of this chart
to the bigger numbers towards the right
into the bottom yeah you know and as he
rightly highlighted um you know as you
kind of make that progression left to
right
um you know there's going to be an
expectation about experience so
generally you start I mean that project
management uh maybe even perspire to
that project coordinator uh kind of make
that progression up and then as you get
more experience you get an opportunity
to kind of get those larger initiatives
that you're going to be responsible for
but don't lose sight of the fact that
it's not just that you need training you
need certifications to kind of
demonstrate you're in a place to do that
as you pointed out agile scrum Masters
um you know very kind of more specific
expertise that organizations are looking
for and there's kind of a duality this
on the one hand you know we hear agile
scrum Masters a lot of what Angel Square
matters focus on tend to be kind of you
know pretty Common Sense techniques
right you know Finding ways to get the
most from people but actually actually
it's it's the art that goes behind that
that that's what organizations are
really prepared to compensate for but um
I mean just look at these numbers Stuart
I mean these These are pretty uh pretty
enticing so I'm not saying that's the
reason to get into this space but it is
a nice reward from pursuing something
that really you know helps you kind of
uh find your fulfillment so yeah I think
this is a sort of a nice side benefit
that is right behind us it's a good
you know as I said one of the personal
projects people undertake is how to
develop their career path and this is
this is part of the information you can
have for that for that project so you
talk talk to us about some of the skills
that people get through
through study through education through
certification that they then turn into
practice yeah absolutely so got a pretty
solid list here it starts off with that
EMP that stands for the project
management professional certification so
this is a certification from the project
management Institute a global
certification
authentication organization so with that
skill with that certification it's
really pointed to the fact that you
understand the whole breadth of project
management this includes knowing how to
you know manage budgets develop
schedules communicate effectively manage
and address risks uh address you know
think about change management all the
things that come into effectively
managing a large-scale project but then
in addition we've got agile we talked a
little bit about uh you know how agile
plays in this new world order that we're
kind of Shifting towards which is all
about you know rapid delivery making
quick adjustments based on feedback so
agile and scrum are a set of kind of
practices that you can lean on to be
more responsive
and of course risk management and this
is some part of project management often
doesn't get as much as attention as it
probably needs to because this is
probably what influences so much about
the success of the project if you take a
schedule and you think of budgets those
two important criteria that
organizations are are looking to
understand for these projects risk is
one of the things that it's going to
affect both of those what's our risk
exposure how do we manage that it gets
back to Mike Tyson and uh
learning how to keep your guard up
because that's one of the ways to manage
risk and also understanding what to do
after you've gotten punched in the face
that's right because that is sort of the
reality we're dealing with because of
projects there will be changes
assumptions you didn't anticipate uh but
and then we look at the right hand side
so this is when we see ideas like lean
Six Sigma so this is a really important
concept I know you've got a lot of
familiarity with this uh this is about
identifying opportunities to remove
waste to become more efficient to use
data to help us understand if we're
performing within sort of a reasonable
range in a Control process so I think
you mentioned this this is sort of a
manufacturing concept that came out like
the 50s 60s
oh much uh I think Six Sigma is more
recent although it evolved from uh the
the Notions of quality control that came
up after World War II
um there's a whole story about American
Quality Control people being called over
to Japan to help rebuilding Japanese
society and their ideas were adopted
there faster than they were back in the
United States because the United States
uh having escaped mass destruction in
World War II they could produce and sell
pretty much everything anything they
wanted
um Japanese of course had fewer
resources and they had to focus more on
the idea of
strict quality control and then
Six Sigma part of that is looking at the
statistical aspects of quality control
and then it developed into lean so
um yeah it's it's something that's
developed out of the the 80s 90s and
then really took off into the 2000s yeah
very applicable to the world we live in
today so as a project manager you're
always going to look out for ways to be
more efficient more effective lean Six
Sigma are great tools to have in your
tool kit there and then we also have
products like Microsoft Project so this
is a a great way in which you can
represent all the work of a large
complex project keep track of it report
on it so having that tool skill set
becomes important
project management offices pmos
organizations often need to create a
special part of their organization a
project manager Office to coordinate all
the different projects make sure project
managers are being effectively onboarded
trained and supported so understanding
the different types of project
management office structures
understanding how to grow expand and
support them and finally
customer-centric digital transformation
we talked a bit about this earlier all
many of those companies you kind of
showed in the previous slide they are
all in that digital transformation space
and organizations are increasingly
recognizing software is a really
important means in which they can
deliver service and products so they're
really focusing on how do we make that
customer Centric so as a project manager
this could be a space you're going to be
working in quite closely having a good
understanding of what success looks like
how to manage these kind of digital
Transformations is indispensable yeah
Brian is that an interesting aspect that
was really driven home with the Advent
of the pandemic is that companies that
thought oh I'm not sure about digital
space and I'm not sure if I'm ready for
it and I'm not sure how to do it uh
suddenly on day one in March of 2020 uh
found out that you had better figure out
how to deal with the digital world
because your employees are all going to
be asked to work from home customers
won't be able to come into your stores
you're going to have to do so much of
your
business and your management online
over that process
had companies seeing well I have a
competitor now who not only survived
this transformation online but leveraged
it to improve their business and start
taking business away from me how do I
deal with that
um
how do I now turn to
digital transformation as an opportunity
rather than a necessity or a threat
right right
those are all
this is the addresses the the concept in
human resources of the t-shaped skill
set where you need to have a broad range
of skills in an area and then you can
pick a place to go deeper and dig down
but the broad range the bar across the
top of the T lets you be more efficient
more flexible and more effective
dealing with your peers
um so you want to look at different
kinds of tools that people use in
Six Sigma in project management in agile
uh all of these different Frameworks and
tools
um are things people will hear about
maybe need to be exposed to maybe need
to become
proficient in
yeah we've touched on a few of these
already some of these acronyms might not
look really familiar but we see domainic
this actually has its roots and some of
what we talked about earlier around lean
Six Sigma the sort of Define measure
analyze interpret and control of course
we've got the agile family that is uh
just become just sort of sweeping in
terms of
um embraced by organizations we
mentioned the pinball that project
management body of knowledge as well as
lean Six Sigma and then the right hand
side
um these are more tools so we've got
minitab statistical analysis tool very
useful for doing some of these Six Sigma
analysis leveraging data we've got jira
which is a Work Management tool
predominantly used in the agile space of
course we've got Microsoft Office I
think we're all familiar with that
PowerPoint word excel and then Microsoft
Project which is specific to management
project management this is where you
create those uh those Gantt charts you
mentioned uh it'll actually do the uh
analysis on critical paths so that tool
because really instrumental to anyone
operating the project management domain
these are sort of the the things that
you would want to have in your school
kit right Brad exactly right that's a
good analogy it's a toolkit
um and then the other thing that's
important is
you become a project manager by doing
projects yeah so
um you know here are some examples of of
projects that people can do in
programs that will help train them to
become project managers and take them
through the process allow them to
exercise the tools understand what
they're doing how their Frameworks apply
in a real world type of environment so
uh
is it possible to underemphasize the
value of this kind of Hands-On work yeah
you really can't underemphasize you're
exactly right I mean this is your
opportunity to kind of as you pointed
out pull all those different tools to
the toolkit apply them to real world
settings you see these uh different you
know portfolio areas that you could work
in
um things like blockchain hey that's a
very exciting very Progressive new
technology and this is again where
project managers often find themselves
you are the sort of the tip of the spear
leading the charge trying to figure out
how to get the most from these new ideas
I'm certain you're going to see ones
associated with AI because that's just a
very emerging space
um but don't lose sight of the fact that
you know important large implementations
like erps these enterprise resource
planning tools that help big companies
you mentioned lahi Martin uh other
companies like that that have huge
Investments that they are making in in
capital assets
um they use erps to kind of keep track
of where are our different resources are
assets or materials how do we bring
those together
um so even though that's sort of more of
a conventional large-scale Software
System still very important to be
effectively managed and this is what
organizations are going to turn to for
project managers to support yeah and one
thing to point out about this type of
thing the brand these are projects that
are drawn from you know the program
we're going to talk about in a minute
but
um
a program like that which allows you to
practice on these types of case studies
and projects means that you're not just
going to take your tools that you've
learned in the program and try to apply
them
kind of in a hit or miss
fashion in your own organization you'll
have a chance to
test run them test drive them and use
them in a similar fashion within this
kind of controlled environment and then
be able to go into your back into your
own organization and say okay now I
understand how to how to do this process
oh yeah
go ahead you can comment well I was just
gonna other observations is going to
share and I think it's kind of important
about this too isn't you kind of
highlighted this the project management
you've become a project manager by
managing projects and you need that
experience but what's also really
important too is to have access to
experts um experienced mentors who can
help you and learn these techniques also
give you guidance at times to say you
know here's something else to consider
here's a different way to approach this
and that's a really important part of
this I think you need to not just learn
these techniques but again support in
understanding how to effectively apply
them yeah
um otherwise you know it's like being
given a a set of Lego blocks and you
could build whatever you want but you're
not going to learn how to necessarily
um build a sculpture of the uh
Millennium Falcon or or the right or you
know Mount Rushmore or that type of
thing without without some coaching
um did want to make one last comment on
this slide blockchain so this is an
interesting example isn't it Brian
because
it's not a matter of
in order to be a project manager on a
project that involves a new technology I
must therefore become expert in that new
technology
it's a matter of I need to understand
enough about the technology so that I
can evaluate what people tell me about
what is feasible and not feasible
that correct oh you're absolutely right
so yeah the expectation isn't you become
an expert in any particular narrow field
but actually you know who the experts
are you leverage their expertise to
assess feasibility is this something
that's actually going to make sense in
this example for a pharmacy it sounds
like they want to evaluate so either
blockchain is going to be good fit for
them that's what you need to understand
as a project manager what are the
outcomes you're kind of trying to
achieve how would you measure success
how do we track that and then you're
relying on the experts the blockchain
experts you're bringing in to actually
facilitate and build the functionality
and you're using their progress and the
work they're completing to assess is
this something we want to continue to do
yeah and that's that's going to apply
with chat GPT and that's going to apply
with any other new technology that comes
out in the world cloud computing
everything that's in the world around us
so this is where I would now ask the
audience for their you
what we're all here because we're
interested in project management as a
career or as a skill set to advance our
career and what has stopped you up till
now from
taking certification in an area like
this
pick one two three or all four of these
leave this open for about another 20
seconds
chance to think about this
I will close the poll in about 10
seconds so
wrap up
hit that submit button I'll close the
poll in five
four three two one
and
share the result we're looking at
um
the most
concerning thing is
finding a program that gives you
practical experience that you can use to
demonstrate that you learn these skills
and can apply them
and then of course people are also
concerned with finding a comprehensive
curriculum and finding them something
that fits into their schedule so
um
I just wanted to
view that I'm going to move on
before we get to the questions and
answers I'm going to introduce this idea
of the
program uh postgraduate program in
project management this is a program
designed by the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst Eisenberg
School of Management supervised by them
delivered by simply learn on the fully
online format so wherever you are in the
world you can take this program
given the pricing in U.S and India but
you can check with us for the pricing in
your local country we have people from
all around the world today
six month program 10 to 15 hours a week
is that a practical schedule
Ryan are people able to succeed
uh in learning what they need to know
through this program in six months yeah
absolutely and I think the you know the
10 to 15 hours a week there's definitely
recognition that for uh for most of the
people participating in this they have
other job responsibilities life
responsibilities we want to find ways in
which they can kind of get the learning
uh apply that knowledge in a manageable
way okay so this pairs very nicely with
those that might already have uh jobs
and careers that now they're looking for
ways to kind of Advance those
um the thing with the six months too is
really want to make sure that we're
really focused on getting you these
skills quickly so you can bring them
into your work environment or look for
that next opportunity that fits the
skills you just developed so uh yeah so
I think it is important uh as you're
highlighted too it's just recognizing
that this is a commitment okay this is
going to require work effort you're
gonna have to apply yourself
um but the nice thing about that 10 to
15 hours a week is you've got lots of
flexibility of when you apply that time
yeah and some of that is the fixed class
schedule for the online
instruction with instructors like
yourself who are who
meet with them in class sessions weekly
you interact with them directly they can
ask you questions you can ask them
questions you can interact with your
your peers in the class
so that's a great aspect of this rather
than having to fly someplace or travel
someplace and sit in a room you get the
experience of being with the instructor
from wherever it is you are other than
those fixed class times you can do the
rest of the work on any
time that you have available throughout
the week so if you want to review
pre-recorded videos that cover different
topics and prepare you for next week's
class you want to do your case studies
and projects
all of those you do in the same online
environment and some of that material
you can even access from your tablet or
smartphone if you want to
um and it covers comprehensive
curriculum we'll talk about that in just
a second here
but um
we go through this together Brian the
kind of steps of the curriculum and how
it's structured here yeah absolutely
what makes this program I think
particularly powerful is uh it is sort
of a series of building blocks to use
the analogy of Lego before I think this
kind of uh fits here so first we want to
get everyone a very strong foundation
and that's where the project management
professional that PMP certification uh
becomes so important
um now recognize too this includes
getting you to the point that you can
successfully pass that exam and our
instructors people like myself we're
close to the PMI we're very familiar
with the exam structure to kind of help
you be successful there and once you've
got that platform then we start layering
in these new or advanced concepts like
agile positioning scrum Master skill
sets so as a project manager you've got
those you can add to the toolbox of
course we're going to give you some
tooling experience with products like
Microsoft Project 2019 the latest
version of this kind of gets you ready
so you can take that tool applied in
your work environments and now we see
that concept of the project management
office the pmo emerging we want to
definitely help you understand not just
what does a good effective pmo look like
but also you might be asked to help
establish one of these or improve one
that already exists and then finally we
bring it all together into that Capstone
project and this is that opportunity not
just to take the learnings that you've
gained through all these other courses
but to work with your instructors and
allow them to give you feedback so you
can really strengthen the the approach
you take to this so you've got something
that is really that Capstone that you
can bring forward show to prospective
employers your current employer and say
hey I I have these skills here's an
example of what I can do leveraging all
these ideas that you've learned through
the program
the electives you see down the right are
think things that you can choose to do
they don't cost extra they're included
in the program but they allow you to
delve deeper into topics based on your
interest and based on how much time you
want to put into the the program so you
want to get certified as a lean Six
Sigma Green Belt you want to learn more
about digital transformation you you are
free to do that in the context of the
program
this is a postgraduate program meaning
you have to have a bachelor's degree can
be in any discipline doesn't have to be
a technical degree
we do want people to come into this
program with a minimum of five years of
work experience so that you understand
where in the
environment where in your work world
the skills will be applied you don't
have to have a programming background of
anything that you need to do on the
digital side will be included in the
instruction but Ryan can you comment on
the importance of having that work
experience
yeah and that is really valuable we need
to you know look to folks you know it's
going to be difficult to apply a lot of
these constant techniques without some
some experience and background to pull
on which is often why if you you look at
getting your project management
certification your PMP certification
from the PMI they will require a minimum
amount of years of work experience now
that doesn't mean you have to be a
project manager in their work experience
but it does mean you've been exposed to
projects you've been part of a project
environment so you've got familiarity
you know that could be gathering
requirements it could be you know you
know implementing something it could be
testing it whatever it might be I think
most of us are going to be able to draw
on that experience but that five-year
work experience is very valuable to kind
of really get the seasoning we often
need to be effective as project managers
yeah
um
we also include in the program something
that the simply learn ads which is
working with our
recruiting talent and professional
development project partners
in the US and in India we offer six
months of access to job assist services
those regions we offer access to
exclusive job portals which allow you to
do confidential Job searches uh we'll
offer resume review and rewrite service
which is very important because your
resume will go through an automated
system before it ever reaches a human
being nowadays so your resume has to be
written two ways one has to pass
through the automated AI valuation bot
that it's going to look for the match
between your experience and skills to
the
job description that was provided by the
employer
so once it passes that filter then your
resume goes to a human being who still
has to be able to look at it recognize
your worth see the highlighted skills
and experience so that
having the the service to rewrite your
resume to fulfill both of those purposes
is really valuable
similarly with the one-on-one interview
prep you know that there are multiple
types of interviews that you have to
pass in order to get a promotion or a
new job including a phone screen
including skills interviews with
potential supervisors and peers
including cultural fit
teamwork interviews so being able to to
practice those one-on-one with real
human beings uh really valuable aspect
of the service again this is available
to you for six months after you complete
the program
and you know we have a number of people
who
have completed the program and
had excellent results
both in terms of what they learned in
terms of what it's have done for their
careers so
this is something that we would hope to
add you to our list
these are all on our website as well
um based on what we've
talked about so far what Brian and I
have shared is this uh
program that you might be interested in
okay and I'll just close this in five
seconds
here's the result a little more than 80
percent of the people responding said
they are interested let me share with
you the result and the bonus that we
talked about so
uh pretty straightforward enrollment
steps and I'm going to put into the chat
right now
the
email address here
you email us we verify your
educational background your work
experience
and if you qualify we send you
a
offer letter
and see in the chat now that email
address is available to you
the next cohort will start on the first
of June so just a couple weeks away
um the induction is your basic
orientation to how to use the learning
management system where to find your
classes what to expect and then the
actual classes start 10 June so
um
we recommend that you contact us right
away if you want to get into that cohort
or if you want to find out about future
cohorts
and as we said there's a bonus offer so
you saw the pricing in U.S and India
again you can check those
uh in your local area by emailing us or
by going to our website and I'll share
that URL momentarily
but you can Finance it with the Mi
financing
and the bonus for attending this webinar
is a 10 discount off the program fees
so you'll be able to take 10 off of
those listed fees
just for being here
today this evening this morning wherever
you are and uh that is our gift to you
for for being with us today
hearing us out
um so again email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
uh I'm gonna before we go into the next
last question here I am going to
um go into the Q a so I'm going to stop
the sharing here
and we'll just go into
the many questions we have in Q a I
don't know how much time we'll have for
all of those but
um
should project managers be open to work
in any type of industry or should they
be focused on a particular industry
that's a great question generally
speaking as a project manager you're not
going to be expected to be so-called a
domain expert but it isn't uncommon for
project managers to develop expertise in
a particular domain so um if that's
something you're getting a lot of
fulfillment from then by all means you
know can I pursue that path to speaking
for my own experience I've worked in
healthcare and oil and gas and
Telecommunications and software
um and many times I'm learning about a
near new product an area and just having
to to figure it out but I'm not expected
to be the expert I'm expected to be able
to manage and coordinate and get a
result
okay
um what do you think about the trend uh
software industry where
teams are being asked to be more
self-driven how to how do project
management skills play into that
environment you know that's a that's a
really powerful question and I think
you're exactly right there is a
absolutely a trend that has been gaining
momentum and this is where agile becomes
so important as a project manager we you
know organizations recognize they want
to sort of thin the many layers of
management they have let their people
doing the work get closer to the
customers that need the work that
they're delivering agile is is really
the the practice that really helps
organizations achieve this this is why
Stuart when you're showing uh you know
some of the salary expectations scrum
Masters are actually kind of top of the
charts because organizations see how
important agile is to kind of help them
connect more with their customers so I
think there is definitely a shift that
direction but again don't lose sight of
the fact that those core project
management ideas principles around
managing to schedules and delivering to
outcomes and addressing risk and people
management they don't go away so you're
just gonna have to take all those
assistant skills and apply them in those
settings yeah
uh how about project management and
contract worker setting
yeah I mean as a I mean I'm a often a
consultant contract worker brought in so
in fact it is a great portable skill to
bring with you uh I really enjoy that
because it gives me so much opportunity
to work across different Industries and
organizations each one sort of a fresh
new experience which I find really kind
of energizing and engaging
um so if that's a path that interests
you then project management is a great
direction to take we have a question
about the recording being shared and yes
we will be sharing the recording I'm
hoping that this is recording properly
for everyone
and
so we'll send a follow-up email with a
copy of this recording
um
what's the future of project management
with in the context of generative AI how
are those tools going to change project
management well I think that is a
fantastic question and I would like to
say I could tell you exactly what that's
going to look like but I I don't think
any of us really know and we know that
AI is advancing very quickly and we're
seeing some really powerful examples of
how it can help us do our work so
there's no doubt it's going to have an
impact on the way all of us are working
I think project management is not going
to be different there however what I can
tell you though all those AI driven
projects initiatives are going to need
some project management to help them get
implemented and improperly and delivered
so
um I think project management is pretty
uh disruption proof you'll always need
project managers regardless of the new
technology or directions that industry
might be taking yeah and
on a practical level if you type into
chat GPT what is my project plan for
implementing this given project it's not
going to know about the resources you
have in your company or the limitations
you have in your company what what
you're able to do so it can give you
generic answers about these are the
kinds of tasks that you might want to
have but they can't really it can't
really manage a project for you right at
that level
um that's not to say that AI tools
aren't being incorporated into project
management tools but that's a different
challenge legal project manager we have
a question from Sean who asks what's the
difference between General project
management and legal project manager
well um you know I think the simple
answer to that is you know legal project
managers can have a you know a little
more narrow Focus project you know
broader project management you learn
skills that can be applied in
construction to software development to
you know customer service whatever it
might be the legal profession has its
own specific needs so examples and a lot
more emphasis on document management a
lot more emphasis on you know privacy
and security and sort of protection of
these important intellectual property
assets
um so now again those are still
important Concepts and every other
aspect of you know project management of
the industry has been a legal profession
this is probably some of the very
specific areas that you need to have
more expertise in
uh is it necessary to get capm or PMP
certification to start as a project
manager not necessarily many people get
introduced to project management mostly
because they're told you know hey we're
in a project can you help us with this
um but those certifications the cap M
certainly PMP are going to give you the
the structure that you can lean on to
kind of more effectively and
successfully manage your projects but
there's no requirement that you know to
become a project manager you must have a
a cap M first that's sort of the
introductory certification that PMI
offers
um no not at all
um
twinkle
who says I'm a business development
management
um
being a fresher where you have to manage
timelines
and teams
uh
how do you get started
some of the the essence of the question
is how do you get started in
understanding
um how to
manage projects especially having to do
with the budgeting scheduling
yeah so you know that that is sort of
the the heart of project management
um and there are skills and techniques
that you're going to need to leverage
part of the reason this program places
that emphasis on the PMP as a foundation
is because the PMP is structured to
answer those questions and give you
those skills and those techniques so you
can build out good schedules with
supporting budgets so
um there's a lot that goes into that and
I think we probably need to have a
number of courses that you progress
through to really get a good answer that
but consider that as sort of the
foundation to kind of get you to the
point of being an effective project
manager yeah we have several questions
that relate to transition into project
management from other areas where you
might not have had the experience where
you might have had experience in doing
other types of tasks how do you get
started uh
in that transition
well you know and actually the good
thing is you've got some work experience
and you know you've probably been
involved in a project in one form or
another through that work experience so
that's the platform by which we're going
to grow those skills
um and this is sort of what you're
highlighting earlier Stuart about how
important it is to have some of the
Practical Real World Experience
um the organizations do want to see you
know some of the seasoning that you can
bring into the role for project managers
so you do need to spend some time in
that space but it can be from any number
of roles and there's lots of ways in
which we can learn about projects just
by being part of a project
um we have a question about the final
Handover process in the sales cycle and
I can talk a little bit to that having
been in that environment the idea of
what you need to to know what you need
to have gathered from the customer's
requirements in order to be able to take
the sales contract and turn it over to
the implementation team that's an
important aspect of project management
is
oh absolutely yeah and it really comes
back to just as you said what are the
requirements what is our customer what
do they need because that's what we have
to deliver so as a project manager you
actually have to get very adapted very
skilled at understanding what your
customer needs and the other part of
that is checking in with that customer
and saying hey I'm building this is this
really what you want and if you want to
make some adjustments tell me now before
I'm all done and then it'd be quite
costly to make those changes so uh yeah
you're absolutely right serious about
getting those requirements understanding
them and making sure we're checking in
as we deliver them yeah in many
environments the project manager gets
involved with the sales team because
they they want to be involved in
defining those requirements before the
contract signs so right right
um
how do you deal with clients who want
something
extra that they don't want build
well you know what's interesting in the
project management first off you know
it's really important to recognize that
anytime you're delivering something that
you have not contractually committed to
you're actually stepping outside of your
scope and a good project manager is
going to manage your scope so if a
person asks for something that wasn't
specified generally to project managers
are going to say well that wasn't
included in our scope if that's
something that you want we absolutely
understand let's let's look at the
impact on our project on its Budget on
its schedule
so we want to be very thoughtful and
sometimes in fact we're going to hear
this term gold plating we we use that in
the project management uh space to
represent when we're doing more than we
need to and you might think at times
that actually it makes your customer
happier but the truth is in fact it can
introduce a lot of additional risk
because when you add more features or
functionality you need to test them and
they could have impacts on other parts
of your product you have to support them
after you go live so sometimes you have
to be careful giving people more than
they ask for often ends up making them
less happy so good project managers
focus on the scope that was agreed to
and they tend not to do the things out
of scope
that's always a good piece of advice for
people who bill by the hours that you
should try to keep everything within
scope so that you're not going to get
picked to death by piecemeal
requirements
um
if a question from somebody who wants to
understand the special skills that you
might need to be a project manager in
construction and one thing I can point
out is that unlike their background they
say as an I.T Logistics and technical
areas
um when you get into construction you
have to deal with things like regulation
permitting a lot of environment
involvement with government agencies and
that type of thing and those are things
that can definitely impact you know when
you can start work when you can move on
from one phase of work to the next
having inspections done and that type of
thing so but these are things that
you'll learn from
the people who who work with you in your
construction area and
so uh what other kind of places would
you recommend somebody look for a kind
of advice and uh well you know that's
that's a great really important
observation is you know as a project
manager first off you're not expected to
know everything so where do you go to
get the information will you go to the
team they have the expertise you go to
your stakeholders the people that you
know work in this domain and Industry
even you know as you highlighted
permitting and regulations well it's
gonna be difficult as a project manager
to know all the different types of
Permitting regulations particularly if
you're doing an implementation in
different parts of the world so you need
to turn to trusted experts who can give
you guidance and advice and then you
incorporate it into your schedule and
your budget
okay I'm looking through here we're
running uh toward the end of our time
but um
can you comment on the different
methodologies and which one is more in
demand now or how they apply in
different situations between things like
prints agile PMA certification
waterfall methods things like that
yeah great question you know I don't
know there's a really simple answer to
this but generally speaking what I would
offer is the following agile in
particular is really kind of getting a
lot of attention from organizations
because of the fact it really focuses on
people it's very people-centric which
organizations recognize as important if
they're going to be successful both
attracting people and enabling them so
agile is a good place to kind of focus
on now that doesn't mean other practices
and techniques like waterfall have have
disappeared no absolutely we're going to
need waterfall particular in domains
like construction which has a lot more
of those physical hard constraints of
waterfall works very effectively in
those spaces you mentioned prince2 well
that's another type of certification
body similar to the project management
Institute prints to a little more
predominant in Europe so if you're
working with a client that's in Europe
maybe you're based in Europe you might
be a little bit more interested in
taking a prince 2 path but the project
management Institute is a global
organization that certification is
recognized in every country around the
world so that's probably your safer bed
so my guidance would be if you had to
pick probably emphasize agile and
project management PMI certification
those that pairing works really
effectively across all Industries
UMass program that we talked about
you're being trained to pass the PMP
test right right exactly
um so when you've completed the the
UMass program you're you're able then to
to move into a test for PMP
certification yes yes in fact um we're
going to put a lot have the emphasis on
getting you exam ready for that PVP exam
and it's a demanding exam so uh we want
to make sure you're positioned to be
successful which includes by the way the
program is going to give you lots of
practice exams because that's a really
good way to kind of get ready for taking
that exam uh practice exams are a really
important part of your preparation
um question about future cohorts and yes
we do regularly start new course of the
program you will want to check with uh
ask us at simplylearn.net or with our
website and I will share the URL shortly
that will give you uh information about
future cohorts
recommend to everybody who's interested
in this program if you're ready to start
or not to email us and we can help you
uh future planning as well uh
uh good interesting question it's a
project manager in the waterfall spaced
closer to the project product owner or
scrum Master the agile space
oh did you say product owner yeah so
this is literally the question is it's a
project manager in the waterfall space
close to a project under or scrum master
in the agile space which I think Works
close more closely with the product
owner if I understand yeah so so in that
context agile uses that term product
owner scrum Master product owner or the
two roles within the scrum framework so
they're going to work very closely
together so agile scrum is really
centered around scrum Master product
owner
um that doesn't mean a warm waterfall
approach can engage with an agile
product owner but uh conventionally we'd
expect to see that really in the agile
space
okay
um we have a question from Dion who asks
uh do I qualify if I don't have a degree
but have between 15 and 20 years of
experience on Mega projects this is
something you'd take up with us by
emailing us
um to find out whether we can relax that
requirement for you based on your
experience I can't answer that for you
right now
um
I think
why have we moved to the agile approach
all of a sudden why are why is project
management General moving to that area
what is the
yeah so you know one of the things that
that agile again emphasizes is people
it's a very people-centric approach to
delivering work
um and what does that mean well it means
that there's going to be a much more
emphasis on interaction collaboration
and I think generally speaking uh we've
learned a lot over you know all the
years of organizations uh developing
growing and and also understanding what
people need is that most of us prefer to
work with one another uh we don't want
to be sort of stuck in a screen filling
out forms so this is where agile has
sort of become really popular the other
thing is if we think of digital
transformation the sort of the shift
more of a digital economy well that
means software software the nice thing
about software it's zeros and ones very
easy to flip a zero to one you can
create software easily you can extend
software easily agile is a great set of
techniques to Leverage The benefits of
digital Technologies and Technical
technical delivery so this is where
agile really kind of come into its its
sort of own in that space
um so I think that that's all the time
we have for questions and you've been
extremely generous with your time uh
Brian so yeah I am going to
um move on to the last part
sometimes when I do this
Zoom kicks me off briefly so if that
happens I apologize I will be back but
let me just share this last
a couple of questions with the audience
yes it's doing that I'll be back in just
a second all right
it
has a
strange I don't see it happening in
other contexts interesting okay
well maybe Stuart is still reconnecting
recording stop recording in progress
when I um
what I share my screen after uh a period
of time it kind of does that to me but
interesting should be okay now
um so let me start this poll
and for those of you who are interested
in enrolling in this program we'd just
like to get an idea of whether you want
to be in the
the
early June cohort or whether you want to
plan further down the road
and we had a question about future
cohorts
and how many people might be looking at
um
even further than that based on your
qualifications experience that type of
thing
I'll leave this open just for another
five seconds
three two one
so
about half of our audience are
interested in either starting in the
June cohort or in one of the immediately
following
and again email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
to get that process started and if
you're looking further down the road
please do email us again and I'm going
to ask this last question
people who are interested
you need us to reach out to you
would you like us to contact you
directly
and I'll leave this open to just 15
seconds or so yes no question
and if you answer yes we will contact
you um
after this webinar in the next day or so
everyone will receive a follow-up email
including the discount code for the
bonus offer and a link to this program
recording
here is the poll result
almost a 60 40 split so again we will
reach out to the folks of you who said
yes
and
let me put into the chat right now the
URL for our
here
sure I don't know if I've been able to
capture all of these things in yes okay
um
just wanted to make sure that I didn't
lose the chat information when I got
kicked off
so here is the URL and the email address
again
in the chat window
now oops now
very good
and
oops I want to say thank you to Brian
for being so very uh as I said generous
with your time with your knowledge with
your Insight with your experience
great to be here thanks so much and I
really enjoyed our talk and our session
today
thank you and I want to thank everybody
here
who took out time from their day their
evening their morning wherever you are
in the world
as I said earlier I've always extremely
impressed and very grateful that we have
an audience that spans
the globe in so many different countries
um it's your QR code and take you also
to our webpage
um
this concludes our webinar we hope we
can welcome you into the Learning
Community with UMass Amherst and simply
learn
and have a great morning evening or
where whatever it is Wherever You Are
that concludes our webinar
thank you great thanks everyone
recording stopped